ELSE, BUT FIRST, SACRIFICING THE
KIDS TO BEAT TRUMP.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
IN EARLY APRIL, I BEGAN TO WARN
ABOUT THE DAMAGE EXTENT OF
LOCKDOWNS WOULD HAVE ON AMERICA.
SINCE THEN, WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
MILLIONS OF JOB LOSSES, ADDED
TRILLIONS TO OUR DEBT, AND
EXPERIENCE TERRIBLE RIOTS.
BUT ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT
HAPPEN AND THE WORST THINGS THAT
HAPPENED WAS HOW MUCH LEARNING
WAS LOST BY OUR KIDS BY BEING
LOCKED OUT OF THE CLASSROOMS.
SO WITH THE TRUMP RECOVERY FULLY
UNDERWAY, DEMOCRATS ARE SHIFTING
BACK TO THEIR DEFAULT POSITION.
SHUT THE ECONOMY DOWN, YES, THAT
IS WHERE THEY ARE NOW.
THAT INCLUDES, OF COURSE, OR
SCHOOLS.
NOW THEY SAY THE RISE OF COVID
INFECTION RATES IN CERTAIN
STATES TO SELL THEIR LATEST
CATTLE CORN.
SPEAK WITH THE UNITED STATES AND
PREFLORAL FROM THE CORONAVIRUS
THE INFECTIOUS DISEASE IS
WARNING TODAY AND RIGHT NOW AS
WE SPEAK THE NUMBER OF DAILY
CASES IS DOUBLE WHAT IT WAS.
TAKE THAT DOUBLE WHAT IT WAS A
MONTH AGO.
>> Laura: ONE ABOUT THE
MORTALITY RATE?
WELL, WHEN PEOPLE SAY ALL OF THE
SCIENCE, TAKE IT WITH A GRAIN OF
SALT BECAUSE SCIENCE BY ITS VERY
NATURE IS ALWAYS EVOLVING.
AS OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
WORLD AROUND US, IMPROVES.
DESPITE THIS, IT IS NEVER
DIFFICULT TO FIND AN EXPERT WHO
WILL TRY TO SCARE YOU INTO
GIVING UP YOUR FREEDOM.
BECAUSE SO MANY STATES WHERE THE
NUMBER OF CASES IN THE THOUSANDS
PER DAY, IT IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO CONTRACT
TRACING AND ISOLATING QUARANTINE
AND THOSE NUMBERS.
IN THOSE AREAS, YOU HAVE TO BE
MOVING BACK TO EVERYONE SHELTER
EMPLOYEES, EVERYONE STAY HOME IF
YOU REALLY WANT TO GET THIS
UNDER CONTROL.
>> Laura: DID YOU HEAR IT?
GOING BACK TO SHELTER IN PLACE.
NOW, YOU SENSE DON’T YOU WEAR
THE DEMOCRATS WILL BE HEADING?
AND THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP COME HE
WILL EITHER SAY ENDANGERING
AMERICA BY INSISTING THAT WE
STAY OPEN.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE MUST CLOSE
DOWN FOR THE NATIONAL GOOD.
NOW, THIS IS A SCORCHED EARTH
APPROACH TO THIS VIRUS, AND ONE
THAT WE ALREADY KNOW DOESN’T
WORK.
NOW, MOST STATES DID ISSUE STAY
AT HOME ORDERS WITH ONLY A
SENSUAL BUSINESS IS OPEN.
GUESS WHAT WE DISCOVERED?
A VIRUS IS STILL OUT THERE WHEN
PEOPLE START MOVING ABOUT AGAIN.
WELL, YES, PEOPLE GET SICK AND
SOME WILL TRAGICALLY DIED,
ESPECIALLY THOSE VULNERABLE.
PEOPLE ARE ELDERLY OR STRUGGLE
WITH DIABETES, AUTOIMMUNE
DISEASES, CANCER OR A HIGH BMI,
THEY ARE ALL VULNERABLE, BUT
THANKFULLY THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WILL TOLERATE
THIS VIRUS.
SOME HAVE ADAPTED OR NATIVE
COMMUNITIES AND THEY WILL NOT
EVEN GET SICK OR SOMETIMES EVEN
TEST POSITIVE WHEN EXPOSED.
NOW AS FOR KIDS UNDER THE AGE OF
18, THEY HAVE A 0% CHANCE OF
BECOMING SERIOUSLY ILL OR DYING
FROM THIS VIRUS.
AGAIN, LESSER THAN ONE OF THOSE
SPECIAL CATEGORIES.
BUT PAY NO ATTENTION TO ACTUAL
FACTS.
LIBERAL SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENTS
AND BLUE STATE GOVERNORS ARE, OF
COURSE, OPTING TOWARDS KEEPING
SCHOOLS CLOSED AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE.
>> I WILL NOT OPEN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
AUGUST 24TH.
IF THE CONDITIONS ARE WHAT THEY
ARE TODAY, OUR REOPENING PLAN
CONTEMPLATES A FACE TO REALITY.
WE ARE STILL IN PHASE ONE TRAIN
PHASE ONE TREND THAT HAS DEGRADE
THE PAST FEW WEEKS.
>> Laura: WELL, THEY TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS RECKLESS LIKE
OPENING IS RECKLESS, WELL,
STEALING FACE-TO-FACE EDUCATION
IS RECKLESS.
IN MIAMI-DADE TO COME ABOUT 60%
OF PARENTS PREFER THE IN SCHOOL
MODEL, 30% SAY IT’S OKAY TO GO
VIRTUAL.
SIDING WITH PARENTS WHO SEE THE
ENORMOUS LONG-TERM DAMAGE MANY
CHILDREN FACE WITHOUT REGULAR IN
SCHOOL INSTRUCTION,
PRESIDENT TRUMP CITED WITH
WORRIED MOTHERS AND FATHERS
TODAY.
>> WE WANT TO REOPEN THE
SCHOOLS.
EVERYBODY WANTS IT, MOMS MOMS
WANTED VOTE, DADS WON IT, KIDS
WANTED TO.
IT’S TIME TO DO IT.
>> WE DON’T WANT PEOPLE TO MAKE
POLITICAL STATEMENTS.
I THINK IT WILL BE GOOD FOR THEM
POLITICALLY SO THEY KEEP THE
SCHOOLS CLOSED.
>> Laura: BUT RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON ADDRESSING THE BRAIN
DRAIN THAT OCCURRED LAST
SEMESTER WITH HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF KIDS IN VIRGINIA,
THE GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHAM IS
ADDRESSING REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
IN A LETTER THAT HAS THE SCHOOL
BOARD YESTERDAY, HE SAID SOME
NAMES AND MASCOTS HAVE
"TRAUMATIZING IMPACT ON
STUDENTS, FAMILIES, TEACHERS,
AND STAFF."
TRAUMATIZING IMPACT?
HOW ABOUT NOT GOING TO SCHOOL
FOR TRAUMATIZING IMPACT, RALPH?
AND STILL TRYING TO RECOVER FROM
THAT INFAMOUS PHOTO.
YOU BET.
IN FAIRFAX COUNTY, LEFT-WING
OFFICIALS JUST ANNOUNCED THAT
PARENTS WOULD HAVE TWO OPTIONS
IN THE FALL "ONE, THEY COULD GO
TWO DAYS A WEEK IN SCHOOL FOR
THEIR KIDS, OR NUMBER TWO, FOUR
DAYS A WEEK, A VIRTUAL
INSTRUCTION.
OKAY, TWO DAYS NO SCHOOL OR FOUR
DAYS VIRTUAL.
BY THE WAY, THERE IS ZERO OF THE
ABILITY TO SWITCH ONCE YOU’VE
MADE THE CHOICE BY NEXT WEEK’S
DEADLINE.
SO WHAT ARE PARENTS WHO WORK
OUTSIDE OF THE HOME, WHAT ARE
THEY SUPPOSED TO DO?
>> WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE NETWORKS
INFORMALLY BUT NOW MORE THAN
EVER, WE NEED THE COMMUNITY
TO WRAPAROUND FAMILIES.
I REALLY HOPE WE CAN HAVE OUR
COMMUNITIES OF FAITH AND OUR
NONPROFITS FIND WAYS TO HELP
SUPPORT THESE FAMILIES IN
GREATER AMOUNTS THAN WE HAVE
EVER DONE BEFORE.
>> Laura: NOW, THAT IS SCUPPER
A BRAND WHO’S A REAL PIECE OF
WORK.
LET’S GET THIS RIGHT, IT IS TOO
DANGEROUS FOR KIDS TO CONGREGATE
IN CLASS AND LEARN AND INTERACT
WITH EACH OTHER’S BUT IT’S OKAY
FOR THEM TO CONGREGATE IN CHURCH
BASEMENTS?
WHAT?
AS USUAL, IF YOU’RE LOOKING FOR
CULPRITS IN THE SCHOOL REGARDING
THE LENGTH BIASED CURRICULUM OR
THE QUESTION OF REOPENING, THE
ROAD ALWAYS LEADS BACK TO THE
REAL DEMOCRAT FIERCEST MOST
LOYAL DONORS.
THE TEACHERS UNION.
WILLIAMS HAD A FAIRFAX COUNTY OF
TEACHER SAY WE WANT KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE,
BUT THAT ALSO MEANS AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE.
OKAY, IF THAT WERE THE CASE, YOU
WOULDN’T HAVE SENT THEM TO
SCHOOL BUT EVEN ANTHONY FAUCI
COLD A TERRIBLE FLU SEASON FOR
2019-2020.
AND THERE IS KIMBERLY ADAMS,
PRESIDENT OF THE FAIRFAX
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION, SHE SAYS
A VACCINATION OR A WIDELY
AVAILABLE TREATMENT FOR COVID-19
FULL RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION.
HEY, NEWS FLASH, AGAIN, ANTHONY
FAUCI HAS TO ADMIT, WE MIGHT NOT
EVER HAVE A VACCINE.
SO SHOULD KIDS JUST BE KEPT OUT
OF SCHOOL FOREVER?
THIS IS LUDICROUS!
TONIGHT, THE VICE PRESIDENT
CALLED THE UNION OUT.
>> WHEN WE HEAR SOME WORD ABOUT
TEACHERS UNIONS BEGINNING
ALREADY TO SAY THEY WILL NOT BE
WILLING TO COME BACK AND SOME
JURISDICTION AROUND THE COUNTRY.
LOOK, WE ALL OUGHT TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS.
>> Laura: WELCOME A FAT
CHANCE.
NEW YORK WHERE INFECTIONS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE DECLINING,
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO STILL HAS
PARENTS AND STUDENTS IN TOTAL
LIMBO.
>> WE HAVE SOME TIME.
THIS IS A VERY FLUID SITUATION.
WHEN WE GET THE DATA, WE WILL
MAKE THE DECISION BUT IN THE
MEANTIME, I’M TELLING ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO COME UP WITH A
REOPENING PLAN.
BUT WE DON’T YET KNOW IF WE ARE
GOING TO REOPEN.
>> Laura: THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
THIS IS LIKE CHILD ABUSE AT SOME
POINT.
FROM A MEDICAL AND COMMENTS AND
STANDPOINT, THE DECISION TO PUT
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL SHOULD BE A
SLAM-DUNK YES.
BUT SINCE JOE BIDEN IS BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR BY THE TEACHERS
UNION, HE WILL RUBBER-STAMP
WHATEVER THEY DECIDE.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS
TELLS FOX NEWS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN DO IT SAFELY IN LINE
WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS.
TRANSLATION, THE UNIONS WANT
MORE MONEY.
>> WE NEED THE MONEY FOR A PP.
NEED THE MONEY FOR EXTRA
TEACHERS.
WE NEED THE MONEY FOR EXTRA
CLEANING AND EXTRA BUSES, BUT MY
MEMBERS REALLY WANT TO BE WITH
THEIR KIDS.
THEY JUST WANT TO BE SAFE FOR
BOTH KIDS AND FOR THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: IS ANYONE FIGHT
ANYTHING THAT THAT WOMAN SAYS?
IS THAT ALL THE TAXPAYERS WILL
BE FUNDING BY THE WAY AND THE
CLEANING CREWS AND HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT MONEY WILL BE ANY
ENOUGH?
WHAT IF THEY PLAN ON WAITING FOR
A VACCINE?
AGAIN, SCHOOLS COULD BE SHUT IN
FOR YEARS.
AND THAT BRINGS US BACK TO THE
BIG QUESTION: ARE THESE SCHOOLS
GOING TO OPEN IN MANY
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
AT LEAST FOR NOW AND
DONALD TRUMP, WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT IS PUTTING PARENTS AND
THEIR CHILDREN FIRST.
BUT THAT COULD CHANGE IN
NOVEMBER.
A VOTE FOR BIDEN PUTS TEACHERS